big mistake women make women go to
advice about men to their girlfriends go
to advice about men to your guy friends
don't go to your single girlfriends for
advice about being in relationships go
to your married friends yeah well I mean
all of your single friends want tequila
Tuesdays to keep happening uh which
means that that you know even if they're
not aware of it it's kind of like
there's this idea of ascending ascending
is becoming a viable mate for women and
maybe even getting it into a
relationship it's very heavily
discouraged because if one of the guys
within a group that are supposed to be
genetic dead ends that have no hope does
do something that creates a pain of oh
well this could happen to me and as soon
as you be believe that this could happen
to me maybe the reason it's not
happening to you is your fault maybe
it's not determined already